so officially rail explorers has been
open for one year so we
we're open on october 11th last year
and it's um just been a fun ride so
we're open year round so we do have
um three different tours but they range
in
how many of them we do a day so in the
mornings we have the southwest ramble
which is just a four and a half
mile pedal bike ride down to railroad
pass casino behind a little picnic area
how's everybody doing tonight
wow go ahead and place your feet on the
pedals and pedal backwards for me
oh good head on down thank you thanks
guys
we're going to expect just a lot of
outdoor fun you got to have some
wildlife that you're going to see along
the way we saw a couple bighorn sheep
last year
ready and then you have the train ride
that takes you back
thought it was great it was awesome very
nice just gave us a chance to get
outside the city i think
we're traveling in our rv it's a way to
get out and
enjoy the outdoors and i just i just
thought it was really a nice package
that they got put together here
it's a different experience for us being
from wyoming we're used to the snow
and that and so this was just a total
different experience than we
have had in the past it's not very
strenuous i mean it's
it's good exercise but it's something
that everybody can do
my team just really wants to do a big
thing and just let you guys celebrate
they take care of there's never dilms
we're sanitizing bikes we're sanitizing
and cleaning bathrooms putting together
hot chocolate packets for you
just so you can go ahead and celebrate
and just have fun and round out 20 20
hopefully on a high note